welcome to this special edition of
Hannity I'm Tammy Bruce in for sea it's
the Friday before Christmas and the US
Supreme Court just offered up a giant
lump of coal to Biden's doj in order to
FastTrack its case against former
president Trump out of Washington DC and
get a verdict before the 2024 election
Federal prosecutors frantically asked
the court for an expedited review of
Trump's presidential immunity claims
today that request was flat out Deni
and many experts are saying there is
little chance that this case will go to
trial before the election here now with
the very latest George Washington law
professor and Fox News contributor
Jonathan Turley Jonathan your columns
are always informative I'm always
tweeting them out telling people to read
the whole thing look this was not
necessarily a complete surprise but give
us your point of view uh with your legal
background what this really means and
how good good of a Christmas gift this
is to president
Trump well it was not a surprise uh many
of us felt that this was the correct
decision what the court did is it stayed
with regular order uh it said that you
know you haven't stated grounds why we
should deny this defendant an entire
layer of appeal that's what Smith was
doing he was saying I I don't want you
to allow Trump to have his case heard
before the DC circuit well that has a
huge impact on a defendant you know
that's part of the record that goes to
the Supreme Court there could be
concessions made in oral argument there
could be mistakes made in oral argument
but more importantly you have more eyes
looking at this issue as these appella
judges State their view so what the
court did is it said we're not going to
treat Trump differently because he's
Trump and you haven't stated a reason
why this has to be expedited and so all
Smith was saying is that look this is a
really really real really really
important case and what the court was
saying is that all right well why if
it's important why shouldn't we take the
time to make sure we get it right yeah
well see exactly I mean the one argument
was because it's important we should
Rush this through in a blur and I think
and Trump's uh argument was because it's
important you want to look at it more
carefully andan wouldn't that be the
natural thing in addition to what you're
what you you've said which is the
natural process that everyone gets to go
through the appell at court the Supreme
Court sees the issue mature if you will
and then they hear those other uh issues
and uh thoughts and and then they'll
make a decision if they have to but
wasn't it obvious at this point didn't
didn't this really kind of highlight the
partisan nature of what Smith is doing
here well I mean the whole argument that
this is so important you should have uh
less judicial review really didn't sit
well obviously with the court they
didn't share the sense of urgency but
more importantly uh knocking out an its
higher level of review for a defendant
is no small matter to that defendant I
so I think that they did stick with
regular order now is this going to upset
the plans of Jack Smith yeah I mean if
you crunch the numbers on this uh it's
not good I mean so you now have an oral
argument set in January even if they put
this on the rocket docket and get out a
decision in a week or two uh Trump can
appeal for an inbank review which is the
larger Court um they have to file those
those briefs and it has to be reviewed
by those judges that's pushing you into
February right uh then you can then
Trump is allowed to go to the Supreme
Court and if the Supreme Court sticks
with regular order that can take months
yeah so
the the March date is gone in all
practicality but so too may be the
chances before the general election well
again this is a very serious issue why
you would want to tie it to an election
Smith says he worries that you know
Trump would be president well then that
is a given or at least they're admitting
that this is a man who the majority of
Americans might want to have be
president so this is this is good news
regardless of what you think of Donald
Trump that this is about regular order
fite the efforts to change that
Professor Turley thank you very much for
joining me I appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else